so since Avengers infinity war came out
there have been a ton of theories
regarding the movie and a ton of
theories regarding Avengers 4 now some
of them are pretty simple some of them
are really out there and a lot of them
don't really make sense but I've
stumbled across a few theories that if
you combine them together they actually
kind of make sense and seem very
plausible for events that happen in
Avengers infinity war and events that
will happen in Avengers 4 this theory is
completely revolved around the time
stone so let's go to Titan when Iron Man
spider-man Doctor Strange and some of
the guardians of the galaxy first show
up so as they are trying to come up with
a plan and they're arguing and some of
them are making no sense
see not winging it isn't really what
they do what exactly is it that they do
kick names take out
all right just get over here please mr.
Lord can you get your folks to circle up
mr. Lord
star-lord is fine as they're arguing and
going over all of these things Doctor
Strange is going forward in time and he
viewed 14 million 605 different outcomes
in which they only won one of them so
only one scenario out of over 14 million
different outcomes so here's the
scenario at the end of the fight between
Doctor Strange and Thanos where he says
you didn't use your greatest weapon he
was actually wrong so let's think about
it over 14 million different scenarios
you can't tell me that that perfect
scenario where they want played out
perfectly right when dr. strange got
back from going forward in time so one
part of this theory is that dr. strange
was actually using the time stone
throughout the whole entire battle
correcting situations that went wrong as
they happened for example when the
battle officially really starts it's
when Ironman drops this huge chunk of
basically planet drops a huge rock on
top of tano's
in which Thanos bursts it open with the
Infinity Gauntlet and attacks Tony Stark
well in other scenarios that could have
happened that dr. strange saw maybe
Thanos ended up killing Tony Stark
somehow so in that moment Doctor Strange
would use the time stone go back in time
and fix the scenario or in a different
scenario they could have actually
managed to get the Infinity Gauntlet
off of Thanos maybe somebody actually
manages to stop star-lord for punching
Thanos in the face and they get the
Infinity Gauntlet but then that scenario
ends up playing out wrong maybe one of
the Avengers tries to put it on and then
finding a garland is just too powerful
for them and they die that would mean
Doctor Strange would have to go back in
time again to get to the one scenario
where they win so he's essentially doing
micro time adjustments as the battle
goes on so he can play it out the right
way and I think the perfect example of
this is when Doctor Strange tells his
cloak
don't let him close his fist it seems
like he just saw a scenario through time
in which it didn't play out the way it
was supposed to so he comes back and to
fix it he has his cloak not let danos
close his fist that way he can't use the
infinity gun
possibly preventing somebody from dying
but more importantly keeping it on the
right scenario and let's go back to
where star-lord punches Thanos in the
face Doctor Strange could have easily
stopped him with ease but he didn't he's
not even yelling at him to not punch
Thanos in the face he's completely
removed from it because he's seen
forward in time he knows that it has to
happen so it's very plausible that
Doctor Strange was actually using the
time stone the whole entire time
correcting events as needed to make sure
they were along this timeline of the one
scenario in which they actually defeat
Thanos so keep in mind that in all of
these 14 million different scenarios he
had to have gone past his own death
because we know that everything that
happened was supposed to happen
everything that played out was supposed
to be played out including dr. Strange's
death this is confirmed to us at the end
where Doctor Strange tells Tony there
was no other way meaning all of this had
to happen in order for them to win so we
know that everything that just happened
was all part of the scenario where they
win which means that Doctor Strange
would have had to go forward in time
past his own death but the question is
how far did he go because he would have
had to have gone to the very ending when
Thanos is defeated to know that they
actually could defeat him and that could
be years and years and years into the
future we've already seen leaked photos
for Avengers 4 where Tony Stark looks a
lot older and it's widely believed that
Avengers 4 will actually take place
several years after the events of
infinity war so if Doctor Strange goes
forward in time into the future who's to
say that he can't actually leave the
time stone with somebody in the future
and then they used the time stone to
send him back that way while all of this
is going on in infinity war future
Avengers are actually going back in time
to events as the Battle of New York in
the first Avengers movie maybe to the
events of Ultron from the age of Ultron
and they're altering events this also
kind of makes sense as to why Doctor
Strange at one point doesn't have the
time stone while fighting Thanos it's
because it's actually in the future and
then when they're done with the time
stone they actually send it back in time
and the time that they sent
back to is actually the exact moment
where Thanos is asking dr. strange for
the time stone and dr. strange actually
gives it to him and they send it back
right in that moment because dr. strange
would have already told them this is the
exact moment where you need to send it
back as you may have noticed it does
sort of flash and twinkle green when dr.
strange sort of plucks it from a star in
the sky it looks like it sort of appears
out of nowhere which is very different
from the beginning where Loki reveals
the tesseract and gives it to Thanos
Loki is using his tricks to hide and
conceal the tesseract he didn't make it
appear as if out of nowhere it was there
the whole time he was just hiding it
it's very different so what if the
reason that the time stone flashes when
it goes into dr. Strange's fingers is
because that is the exact moment where
the time stone is sent back to his
present time this would also make sense
as to why dr. strange was so willing to
give the time stone to Thanos because if
you think about it the whole movie dr.
strange is saying
danos can't get his hands on the time
stone it is my sole purpose to protect
the time stone if it comes down stark to
saving you or the kid or the time stone
guess what I'm saving the time stone so
why did dr. strange so willingly give up
the time stone at the end especially
when he knew that Thanos already had
four out of the six Infinity stones so
this explains why he was so willing to
give it to him at the end and this is
where the importance of Tony Stark comes
in Doctor Strange had to make sure that
Tony Stark survived he's the only one
that's smart enough to figure out the
time stone so it's believed that in
Avengers 4 when it's just Tony Stark and
nebula after everyone has turned to dust
the time stone will actually appear to
Tony Stark someone from the future will
send Tony Stark the time stone in that
moment once Tony Stark has the time
stone he will begin to study it and
eventually use it much like he did in
age of Ultron with the mine stone and
maybe once he has the time stone and
studies it he can somehow use it to
access the quantum realm because in the
mid credit scenes of ant-man and the
loss there's talk of a time vortex
inside the
quantum realm I bet you that somehow the
time stone could access that so maybe
this is how ant-man could be rescued and
also maybe bringing Captain Marvel into
Avengers 4 because there's been talk
about Captain Marvel being inside the
quantum realm somehow but we'll have to
wait until Captain Marvel comes out to
see what that is all about and this
could also potentially explain why
Thanos is Gauntlet kind of breaks after
the snap he's using a time stone that
comes from a reality where the Avengers
used it and have already won and
defeated Thanos this sort of creates a
paradox and I think Doctor Strange was
well aware of what it would do this
paradox of using a time stone from a
mutually exclusive reality breaks the
Infinity Gauntlet and in turn advances
dr. Strange's plan because this now
allows the Avengers to attack Thanos
because he doesn't have the ultimate
power of the Infinity Gauntlet to do
basically whatever his heart desires so
this is the theory of some events that
happened during Avengers infinity war
that we didn't see but events that we
might see happen in Avengers 4 it's
pretty messy but when you have
time-travel involved in a movie you
invite it to get messy and again it
seems very plausible to me seems very
doable and it goes along with the story
very well and it makes sense to me now
obviously this is just a theory and
there's no real way to know what is
going to happen in Avengers 4 until it
comes out the Risa brothers have said
that this movie is their best work and
it's gonna be on a completely different
level and it's going to be unlike
anything that they've ever done before
and unlike anything that we've seen so
far in the MCU
so there's a lot that can happen there's
a lot that is going to happen and some
of what I mentioned in here very well
could happen so what are your thoughts
on this theory do you think that this
theory is plausible and could happen
despite whether it does or not and if so
do you think that it's a story route
that the Russo brothers could have went
down or do you think that there is just
no way that we're going to see any of
this happen in Avengers 4 let me know
what you all think in the comments below
please hit that thumbs up button before
you leave and be sure to subscribe to my
channel so you can stay
up-to-date with everything happening
with a vendors for Marvel DC and
everything superhero thank you so much
for watching this video
woof woof where's your guy
dude you're embarrassing me from the
wizard
you